[Music]
a food bank in govan is a world away
from mixing with wealthy donors but this
was the first time we've seen the prince
since the damaging claims about
donations to his charity and potential
promises to help secure honours and
british citizenship
hugely embarrassing for the prince who'd
rather the attention was on how the
money is spent
it isn't surprising to hear that wealthy
individuals would want to go out their
way to support some of the prince's
charitable endeavors but what is
troubling about this story is the
potential conduct of some of those
closest to him and how they've maybe
been using his name
and title
the claims involve michael fawcett one
of his closest aides and chief executive
of his charitable foundation who is
alleged made promises to saudi
businessman mafus mariah
who gave 1.5 million pounds to help
restore buildings like dumfries house in
airship the prince's foundation which is
also based there are now investigating
but it is another distraction
overshadowing important work including
it suggested a royal charm offensive in
scotland to rival calls for independence
john mcclellan is a journalist and
conservative councillor based in
edinburgh people have made their minds
up and those who think that the royal
family uh
carrying out engagements in scotland is
a political act and designed to thwart
the independence movement i'm going to
think that anyway
um and and i i don't i don't see
that changing attitudes towards them uh
not nor do i see um a a greater number
of engagements
um
in in scotland changing attitudes uh in
against independence
beautiful drinks oh thank you very much
they are good at this and will always
have their supporters
they're very important people
they're very precious and i think the
people who disagree
really don't understand the amount of
effort and work they put into what they
do i think it's brilliant so idea so
they can show their faces that they do
actually come to places that that are
quite down you know so i work in the
local area and i just think that it's
brilliant so it's my lunch break so i'm
spending my lunch coming to say hi
we're told the prince didn't know about
the claims but for a future king whose
reputation has improved in recent years
the allegations simply cannot be ignored
rhiannon mills sky news in glasgow